before we dive into Limitless I'd love
to get your reaction on your Avengers
co-star Chris Evans being named the
sexiest man alive what do you think
about time really I've been saying it
for years the world's finally catching
up it's a good looking human he sure is
well deserved you've held the title
before many years ago past my Prime now
so it's a passing of the torch yeah oh
whatever past his Prime please and you
are not Pastor Prime in this series
Limitless I got to tell you Chris it is
something why did you want to put your
body your mind through this experience
and these epic challenges a lot of
reasons I mean Darren Aronofsky at the
the Helm of this thing
um it pitched me the series a number of
years ago it's about longevity how to
live a longer healthier better life and
I thought absolutely I'm Keen so it's
most of us and I was uh previewed a
number of different experts in their
food longevity from all around the world
and put me through a series of grueling
physical and mental emotional challenges
and um
many many takeaways that I hope an
audience also experience and and
education without being kind of having
any science shoved under your face it's
it's entertaining but educational and so
I'm so excited for people to see it from
young kids to adults and so on there's
something for all of us to take from it
was there one challenge in particular
that you thought oh I just don't know if
I can do it all of them yeah it was
there hadn't been been one I did a four
day water fast and that was that was
intense were you angry incredibly hangry
that kind of epitome of that I did a
swim in the Arctic Ocean uh in uh 35
degrees Fahrenheit 2 degrees Celsius
Waters even Road board shorts even Ross
said he can't believe that you did that
because people will train for some time
not four five days I had Ross on my
shoulder yelling and screaming and
reminding me he said you're going to
feel like you're dying which in effect
you are if you stay in too long but
we're not going to let you be in that
long because override that and know that
the back you know believe the science
that you can do this and on we went and
it was uh it was a excruciating
experience in the name of science so
yeah but your brothers were there for
that challenge how much do those
Hemsworth brothers help you out were
they encouraging abusive but in in the
best way you know his brother should be
it's kind of the self-deprecating
abusive quality that siblings provide
which is a great motivation to get over
the Finish Line what is your kids make
of this and Elsa as well
Elsa was a part of the series and some
of the episodes and and kept sort of
saying
you sure you should do that is that safe
are you gonna be okay
we need our Thor at the end of the day
but finally to take away that first
episode the stressor episode
um what did you take for that and how
are you applying some of those skills
the breathing techniques the Box
breathing technique and other things
into managing your lifestyle your
professional life and balancing the
stresses of it it was just you know
understanding how important it is to
take pause and be still and not be in a
state of fight or flight which I think
most of us find ourselves in day to day
going from activity to activity and
realizing how detrimental that is in
your Healthy short-term and your long
term so it was a great reminder to
adjust just to be present and uh and
breathe and slow down a bit you know
[Music]